okay people so I don't usually use my
webcam d'accord videos because the
quality is lesser but I feel like it
might be more entertaining if you
actually watch me react live to the
first time I see the Academy Awards that
way you'll get an absolutely completely
genuine reaction and I think it'll be a
little more entertaining that way a
little more fun than that you know like
a little more like you're actually like
you're in my room I care I can creep it
on me you know yeah anyway okay so
there's a whole bunch of people
whispering in a little room and they're
not saying anything and it's very
suspenseful and how about you but I'm
feeling I'm feeling sweaty tell me this
is a three minute warning to air three
minutes everyone
amazing I'm Tom shirt
president of the Academy this morning we
will share the news we've all been
waiting for
I'm very happy too many people will be
snubbed that's actress nominees Jennifer
Lawrence like to nominate her good
morning the 2011 nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are be released we show
in the artist Jessica Chastain in the
help the healthy in bridesmaids whoa
Janet McTeer in Albert Nobbs huh and
Octavia Spencer into hell yeah for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role the nominees are Kenneth Branagh
and My Week With Marilyn Jonah Hill and
Moneyball Oh Nick Nolte in warrior floor
what a plumber and beginner good and Max
von Sydow and Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close he's good he's good but
best for one actress in a leading role
the nominees are Glenn Close and Albert
Nobbs
Viola Davis to help Rooney Mara
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo Meryl
Streep in the our course of course and
Michelle Williams in my week with Mara
I'm very pleased with these the nominees
for Best Performance by
actor in a leading role are dannion
Bashir in a better life George Clooney
in the descendants John Dujardin in the
artist Jean Dujardin Gary Oldman and
Tinker Tailor zones mine and Brad Pitt
and Moneyball nice who did they achieve
me Michael Fassbender shame what the
hell Ahsan of is Jesus for the artist
come on
Nicolas Winding repair the pain for the
descendants Nicolas Winding reference
what and Scorsese for you go Nicolas
Winding riffin Woody Allen for midnight
in panic Ulis whining Ruffin Terrence
Malick for The Tree of Life my god
that's original screenplay the nominees
are michelle has an abuse for the artist
will write will whatever mom although
and Kristen Wiig for Brides name 50/50
right Lacey Shandor for margin call
Woody Allen for Midnight in Paris right
50/50 and a scarf for dolly for a
separation for adapted screenplay comedy
isn't it Alexander Payne that faxon and
jim rash for the descendants John Logan
for you go George Clooney grant Heslov
and boom thank you good what mean way
that would be my pick means alien Aaron
Sorkin and Stan Shevin for Moneyball and
Bridget O'Connor and he too strong for
Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy really that
script was like a foreign language film
mind bender from Belgium full head from
Israel footnote from Poland in darkness
from Canada once year lays arm a
separation and from Iran a separation
for Best Animated Feature Film the
nominees are
don't put cars to a cat in Paris my
wangan Yeol and Jean who Phil Coley
Chico and Ruby and Rita
Fernando Schwab a Javier my number cars
tail hummus list Kung Fu Panda 2
Jennifer yuh Nelson good Puss in Boots
Chris Miller good tenth and wrangle Gore
Verbinski
and finally I'm pleased to announce that
the film selected as Best Best Picture
nominees for 2011 are War Horse Steven
Spielberg and Kathleen Kennedy producers
the artist Thomas Legman producer
Moneyball Michael De Luca large ahora
'but that's the premise at Pitt that's
very surprising the descendants Jim
Burke Alexander Payne and Jim Taylor
producers The Tree of Life nominees to
be determined Midnight in Paris Letty
Aronson and Stephen Tenenbaum group
producers the help from Cyrene and Chris
Columbus and Michael Barr Nathan
producers Hugo
Graham King and Martin Scorsese
producers and Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close Scott Rudin producer
please join us on February 26th when we
celebrate the magic of the movies thank
you thank you
well that is why a live reaction was a
good jeez Louise
why would you nominate Extremely Loud
and Incredibly Close why in the world
you nominate that that movie was dumb
no one that movie was stupid okay look
they completely stick did they hmm does
the Academy really think that Extremely
Loud and Incredibly Close is better than
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo or drive
or I mean what am I forgetting something
what am I forgetting come on I mean
fifty-fifty for goodness sakes Academy
so what if it's funny 5050
how about a Andy Serkis come on just
nominate I mean deserves it Andy Serkis
oh and of course not one single
nomination for drive wonderful just
wonderful Academy a lot of really good
choices in there though some really cool
things that I was happy about that I saw
some nominations I didn't expect to see
that I was glad it wasn't just like an
awful snobbery of awfulness I've seen
worse trust me Dark Knight anything
Christopher Nolan does basically a snub
but really I didn't really mind anything
until the very last announcement I mean
why would you nominate that movie
why that movie was literally the
definition of Oscar bait I hope it wins
nothing just don't uh I'm so annoyed had
that but other than that for the most
part I really enjoyed the nominations I
think a lot of them were good there was
just a few that I would have liked to
have seen Ryan Gosling NOLA for him
Michael Fassbender no love for him I
mean come on Academy what are you doing
Michael Fassbender Michael FAAST
bender was one of the best actors in so
many different ways of 2011 you need to
check your stuff academy but besides
that pretty good nominations extremely
loud it has no place on that list at all
that that just make the academy seem
really stupid but for the most
and I enjoy them so yeah those my
reactions I'm glad I did this live that
was a good good way to do this so I let
me know you guys think of the Academy
Awards I'd like to know and thanks for
watching I appreciate it if you liked
this you can subscribe to my channel and
get stuck me